[Musique]
n'est pas de bois d'olives de la
fondation père favron situé à st pierre
a organisé une journée portes ouvertes
ce vendredi 10 juin un moment de
rencontre et d'échangé qui tend à rompre
l'isolément des personnes âgées en
situation de handicap
c'est la première des journées portes
ouvertes de la fondation père favron
puisque dans l'ensemble des
établissements sur les neuf sites de la
fondation nous allons organiser ces
journées s'organisent traditionnellement
au mois de juin puisque ça tourne autour
de la date de la mort du pérou qui a
lieu le 19 juin 1960 j'ai donc ce mois
est consacré
dans les établissements à l'organisation
de journées portes ouvertes de manière à
faire se rencontrent les familles et les
résidents
le personnel
et l'ensemble des établissements
le président du département syrie mais
le coeur a souhaité participer à
l'événement et n'est pas venu les mains
vides dans le cadre du plan bien-être il
a offert des paniers gourmands aux
résidents quand je rencontre nos aînés
je suis un président heureux il ya un
travail remarquable qui est fait dans
ces structures et quand je me déplace
bien c'est aussi pour témoigner de la
solidarité
du département bien sûr envers les
établissements mais surtout envers
toutes ces familles ces personnes qui
sont accueillis et hébergés
et je leur souhaite bien évidemment
d'abord une très bonne santé mais
excellente santé et que l soit bien
accompagné prises en considération ceret
melchior a salué la fondation père
favron qui ont obtenu le label
humanitude gars en à prendre soin tout
en douceur dans leur esprit de la
singularité de la citoyenneté des
personnes âgées
[Musique]